el acuerdo de seguridad firmado por
china y las islas salomón tiene sus
antecedentes en 2019 entonces las islas
dejaron de lado a taiwán y establecieron
relaciones diplomáticas con china que el
movimiento generó muchas tensiones no
sólo en el interior sino con sus socios
tradicionales y especialmente con
australia la que sólo separan dos mil
kilómetros los peores temores de
camberra se hicieron realidad el mes
pasado cuando emergieron detalles del
borrador del acuerdo por un lado se
permite que la marina china se abastezca
y haga escalas en los puertos de la isla
por el otro también se permite que el
ejército chino se despliegue por su
territorio para asegurar el orden social
pero sólo después de que se lo haya
solicitado el gobierno insular eeuu y
australia han manifestado en numerosas
ocasiones su miedo a que el objetivo
final de este acuerdo sea el
establecimiento de una base militar
china a pesar de que las dos partes
firmantes lo han desmentido una y otra
vez con vehemencia es seguro que este
acuerdo no va a rebajar la tensión en el
asia-pacífico donde tanto eeuu como
chinas han citado para dirimir la
primacía global pekín denuncia a
washington por su mentalidad propia de
la guerra fría por mantener decenas de
bases militares y por apadrinar
organizaciones de defensa como el august